meantime a clark county school district
teacher retires after decades of
teaching and she was hoping to be paid
for her hundreds of unused sick days but
to her surprise her check was nothing
like she expected now she wants to warn
others she spoke with 8 news now
reporter victoria saha who joins us now
with more victoria
cynthia darcy has been with the district
for over 30 years every year she would
get around 15 sick days but she wouldn't
use many because she knew finding a
substitute would be hard and also in
hopes to cash them out at retirement
which is what the what is written in the
negotiated agreement between the
district and this union after looking
forward to a big check she was
disappointed and took to social media to
warn other teachers
cynthia darcy was dedicated to the clark
county school district for 31 years this
was my first year of teaching check out
that huge 80s hair she took to social
media after receiving her check from the
school district for her unused sick time
in her post she claims she racked up 306
sick days but the negotiated agreement
states only a hundred of those days will
be paid out she shows us her check of
what she was paid for a hundred days her
total was 467 dollars after taxes and it
shows each unused sick day was worth
five dollars and ten cents it's reading
the fine fine print to
learn that they will only pay for a
hundred i did reach out to the school
district to find out exactly how those
daily rates are calculated they referred
me back to the negotiated agreement it
says the district shall allocate the sum
of 196 thousand and 197 dollars and 24
cents and use that amount to come up
with the rate to divide that between the
teachers retiring that year you don't
know how many other teachers are
retiring they don't explain what that
actually means to a single teacher
dorsey claims a substitute shortage
would often times force her to not use
her sick time but what frustrates her is
that throughout most of her career
substitutes would get paid ninety
dollars a day and by her not using a
hundred of those sick days
she saved the school district nine
thousand dollars
and when finding out dr jesus jarrod
will be getting a huge check after being
ousted from his superintendent role
darcy is rethinking her decisions what a
difference i wish i'd used him
earlier this year the school board of
trustees increased the pay of
substitutes from ninety dollars to a
hundred and ten dollars a day darcy
tells me she doesn't regret showing up
for her students even when she was sick
but wish teachers were appreciated more
she hopes her message will allow
teachers to put themselves first